I want you to think of how you approach the idea of the quality of your health
care in this country, in the United States.
For those of you who are watching this from the United States.
Typically, you would ask around to make sure that you had a good doctor.
You would try to get a referral from your existing primary care provider,
so-called PCP.
Or would ask your friends who had been in similar situations,
and triangulate and figure out who the good doctors were.
But you would also have the support of a variety of institutional mechanisms
that would ensure that the quality of the doctor that you were seeing
was sufficiently high, so as to reassure you
that your care was being put in a good person's hands.
Not just a competent professional, but also a good ethical person.
There are lists published monthly, annually,
semi-annually in the United States on the best doctors,
and this and that specialty.
There are, of course, institutions that are ranked and rated
all the time by different commissions of the US government.
There are magazines that specialize in ranking doctors and medical care
facilities on a variety of dimensions.
There is a veritable cornucopia of different ratings.
And you might have the opposite problem that you'd
have in other parts of the world-- that here there
is too much data to base your decision on.
But you would not be short of being able to get the right information that you
need to make a good choice of a doctor.
That information is woefully missing in most parts of the world.
You would, of course, still essentially ask your friends and family,
to figure out who the good doctors were.
But beyond that, you would have much less assurance
that the doctor that you are seeing is of acceptably high quality.
Now, of course, if you were in the privileged classes,
you would find a way around this.
But for the vast majority of people in South Asia, in developing countries,
it is very hard to access a doctor, let alone worry about the possibility
that the doctor is not credentialed, is not ethical, is not
sufficiently trained, has not had continued education.
These are all the niceties that don't even cross the minds of anybody.
If there is a doctor with a Red Cross sign outside,
that seems to work just fine.
This absence of information is what I refer to as an institutional void.
That's a mouthful.
But void simply refers to the idea that something is missing.
Here, the piece of information that's missing
is reliable information about the doctor.
How do I find a good primary care provider?
How do I find a good gastroenterologist?
How do I find a good ophthalmologist?
How do I find a good oncologist?
Depending on what my need is, it is fiendishly difficult.
In a sense, when you peel back the complexities,
and the ethical dimensions, and the human dimensions of health care,
there is a basic elemental need here, which
is to bring together people who have something to exchange.
Economists would call this buyers and sellers coming together.
Here, the buyer is a patient.
He-- I'm going to use he, since I'm thinking of myself--
is a buyer of medical services.
And the doctor is the seller of medical services.
Now I realize calling them buyers and sellers isn't the most natural way,
but bear with me for a second.
To get the buyer and seller to come together,
we basically need a little bit of information that's credible.
So that the buyer can find the seller, and vice versa.
That information is actually so taken for granted in different parts
of the world.
And so completely difficult to engineer in an institutionalized capacity.
When you stop to think what it takes to make sure
that information is reliable, easily accessible, credible, reproducible,
regeneratable-- to coin a word, for a second.
You realize that there's a lot of complexity to it.
And when that information is not there, then you have the most basic breakdown.
A doctor can't find his patient, and a patient can't find his doctor.
And medical care does not get delivered.
And that's a problem.